[Music]  this sure beats that old rat race now  it's time to take the world by storm yes  I'm all caught up with work on the clock  out and hit the poo  some of us are trying to work finally a  little time off  [Music]  got to get a gig I'm not gonna work  again I'll never have a job I got to get  a gig I need a job I get a gig I need to  job I got a need a gig for the skills I  offer $50 an hour is quite reasonable  okay thank you how about we give you a  sandwich that'll be fine this morning  father I woke up at noon and work from  the tub I may not understand your  lifestyle but I respect you son I think  my son is a boxcar hobo gotta get a job  gotta get a job  dial-in focus got to get a job